hi I'm Chris brains waste management  officer team bridge district council  where today at the launch of our big  tidy up campaign we've been selected as  national tidy up champions as part of  the keeper and tidy campaign and we've  launched today with three little picking  events two on the land in the local  facility of our offices and also one  along the local rivers and tributaries  on kayaks which is great we've got whole  load of material in as you can see  behind us it's what we've hauled in  today and yeah a lot of this stuff was  recyclables a lot of tins and cans of  plastic bottles that sort of thing so  that will get sort and reprocessed and  yeah we're going to be organized in 15  or more events between now and March  next year engage in local community  getting all sorts of people involved to  help us out and tidy teamriche together